allons finir à poil et dans l'est que
dans les commerces de campagne on est
certain que ça finira comme ça
[Musique]
c'est de créer une entreprise c'est pour
la faire pour la développer pour la
faire prospérer et déjà qu'on a eu un
premier continent qui a été très dur
dans la restauration va y avoir beaucoup
beaucoup de dégâts ces gens là qui
décide on voit qu'ils sont un peu hors
sol ils sont complètement déconnectés de
la réalité nous écoute pas de toute
façon on n'a jamais personne qui vient
nous voir au niveau du gouvernement
comment je juge la réaction du
gouvernement
eh ben de toute façon amère impression
qu'ils s'en moquent
et alors sur l'histoire du monde est
essentielle essentiellement d'essentiel
là c'est un mépris total de de ce que
peut être un commerce dit non essentiels
[Musique]
on laisse des cantines scolaires on
laisse les cantines professionnel enfin
d'entreprise ouverte
et puis nous les restaurateurs petit
restaurateur de campagne dans lequel on
a à peine 20 couverts
eh bien on se retrouve à fermer applique
les normes sanitaires donc si on peut
laisser ouvert les cantines entreprises
je ne vois pas pourquoi on ne peut pas
laisser ouvert des petits restaurants
qui respectent les normes sanitaires
[Musique]
moi j ai eu aucun grief contre le
commerce en ligne dès qu'on commence à
parler d' amazon qui fait de
l'optimisation fiscale européenne en
déclarant ses revenus au luxembourg
peuvent éviter payer des impôts en
france
là ça m'ennuie beaucoup plus
[Musique]
de toute façon à quoi personne c'est pas
des êtres dont il a envie c'est pouvoir
travailler c'est de pouvoir faire son
métier de commerçant